Salut à tous c'est Pêcheurs de Trésors.
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes à Bordeaux
ou on a trouvé un petit canal
On a envie de savoir ce qui se cache
sous l'eau. Première fois à Bordeaux,
on est en compagnie
de notre nouvelle stagiaire, Jade
et de notre deuxième stagiaire, Sydney,
qui est là avec Rasta
J'ai déjà quelque chose
Voyons voir tout de suite
ce que ce canal nous réserve
Du câble
Du câble d'acier.
J'ai peut être eu un truc au milieu
mais ce n'est pas très lourd.
On va regarder.
OK, juste un tube, enfin une barre
La stagiaire a une belle trouvaille là je pense
Ca bulle
Alors, qu'est ce que c'est ?
Comment ca s'appelle ?
Un étai
Elle a failli tomber dans l'eau.
Attend, j'ai un parpaing avec
Pour ça que c'est lourd
Ah ouais, d'accord.
Oh oui, belle trouvaille.
J'en ai chié
Un parpaing c'est
une première.
Super
Il fait le travail ton petit aimant
Ben ouais
Le Terror de chez Maison de la Détection.
Si vous voulez pêcher des parpaings.
Belle trouvaille, sympa.
OK, j'ai une clé USB,
ça peut être intéressant ça.
Selon ce qu'elle contient,
On est sur un nouveau spot très sympa,
toujours à Bordeaux.
Et regardez ce qu'à repéré Rasta
Des tortues
On va essayer de ne pas les assommer
avec les aimants
On va tirer loin, elles vont partir.
Très sympa en tout cas de voir ça.
Surtout qu'elles sont grosses, elles doivent se plaire ici
Des canards et un ragondin.
Regardez la biodiversité ici, c'est ouf !
On a la totale.
Un beau petit ragondin.
J'espère que c'est propre ici
pour tous ces animaux,
on va voir
Si c'est propre on ne va pas les embêter
J'ai eu quelque chose de cette passerelle.
On a changé d'endroit, c'est le lieu
des tortues et des ragondins.
C'est assez lourd, ça peut être un vélo
Non. Non, un tube
C'est une borne de signalisation.
C'est super lourd
Tu veux que je t'aide ?
Je veux bien de l'aide.
Il est remplie d'eau, pour ça que c'est lourd
Fais attention aux aimants avec la barrière.
On va se verser de l'eau dessus si on le soulève comme ça.
On essaie de verser
Tu le bascule pour qu'il se verse ?
Regardez comme on galère juste pour un plot
Tu le fais Jade ?
Moi je l'attrape
Ben voilà
Il va être moins lourd, non ?
Ouais
Super
Attention aux chiens
Voilà la première trouvaille
sur ce nouveau spot.
On va continuer.
On va voir ce qu'on trouve ici.
Il n'est pas vieux
C'est tout propre ici, c'est tout neuf
Deuxième trouvaille, on va voir ce que c'est
C'est moins lourd
Quoi que ...
Peut être pareil les gars
C'est pareil !
Mais dans le bon sens.
Il se vide là
Ca devrait le faire
Vu qu'il est vide, ça passe seul
Et voilà,
Deuxième
Là, ça bulle
J'ai ramassé des petits objets je crois, enfin
Parce que les gros, non merci.
Voilà, j'ai quelque chose d'intéressant.
J'aime le poids.
Un antivol de scooter
Tu vois qu'il y a des trucs
Tu as le dessus du poteau
Ah oui, la partie supérieur
J'ai failli perdre un doigt.
C'est dangereux, c'est dangereux,
c'est dangereux.
J'ai eu vraiment de la chance.
J'ai eu un peu mal mais ça va
C'est la partie supérieur d'un troisième.
Il faut le trouver
Il y a un truc dans la vase ici.
Je sens quelque chose
Regardez quand on creuse un peu
Il n'est pas mal ce spot
Au premier abord on n'aurait pas dit
Je l'ai
C'est assez lourd.
Aller, vélos, vélos, vélos.
On y croit
Oui, oui, les enfants
Je vais avoir besoin d'aide
Avec mon aimant ou que je l'attrape ?
Aide moi avec ton aimant
Le mien peut lâcher
Mon premier vélo de
la journée, qui est peut être électrique.
Attends, je venais à l'instant de jeter mon aimant un peu loin
Vraiment le style de spot où
je savais qu'il y allait avoir un vélo,
Je connais
En plus, il y avait des gens un peu curieux
qui me demandaient ce qu'on faisait.
Et Quentin leur a dit oui, il y a des vélos,
des fois
Ils étaient surpris qu'on trouve des vélos
Comme quoi
Comme quoi on dit n'importe quoi,
mais pas tout le temps.
On arrive à prévoir quand même un peu.
Je vais essayer de
le choper, il est par là
Ouais, parfait
Il n'est pas très vieux
Il est électrique, il y a des câbles
Mais pas très lourd
C'est un vélo de la ville
Parfait, attention Sydney
Il y a l'antivol
Ah oui l'antivol ici.
Bizarre cet antivole
Je ne pense pas qu'il puisse rouler
Alors que ça le bleu, ça veut dire que c'est un Vélib
Ouais, sympa.
Pour l'instant,
c'est moi qui ai la plus belle trouvaille.
Bon, allez, on continue.
Ah oui, ils ont volé la batterie.
Peut être, quelque chose qui a été volé
Ouais une pièce !
C'est quoi ?
0,05€ d'euros, ok.
N'empêche que ça reste de l'argent. Je garde
Voyons voir ce qu'on
trouve dans ce point d'eau
En espérant ne pas assommer de tortues.
Si vous avez une idée en commentaire,
je remontre plein de microbilles
de différentes tailles
Elles sont aimantées
Intéressant
Je ne sais pas trop, on n'a jamais vu ça.
Un métal spécial,
ça fait comme du plomb, mais aimanté.
On va aller sur un nouveau spot,
donc là, on est en plein Bordeaux
cette fois ci,
Un petit port
Mais en attendant, on a trouvé un endroit
avec plein de canettes
Elle n'est pas aimanté celle là
Non, c'est la poussière
On va ramasser toutes les canettes,
qu'elles soient en aluminium ou pas.
Il faut savoir qu'une canette en alu
au prix du poids, c'est environ 0,03€
Ouais donc c'est pas mal,
il y en a partout.
On va voir combien on arrive
à en prendre
C'est parti
Il y a du plastique aussi,
mais comme il n'y a pas de poubelles,
on ne peut pas le ramasser.
Nous on va faire la partie recyclage,
Il y a des moustiques tigres.
Oui ça pique
Regardez le résultat en cinq minutes
Ca va sentir bon ça par contre ...
L'odeur est horrible, 5 minutes et un seau complet
Et encore, on n'a pas tout prit
Pas mal
On a pas joué 1€, peut être
plus.
Si c'est que de l'aluminium, ouais peut être plus
Si tu en as 10, ça fait  0,30€
Une trentaine ça fait 1 euro
Regardez ce que j'ai trouvé aussi
C'est un PC ?
Une Xbox
Mais non ...
A vendre
Ouais, enfin quelque chose !
Juste un tournevis.
Un tournevis presque comme neuf
La corde, tant pis pour elle,
c'est pas mal.
C'est
la meilleure trouvaille de l'endroit.
Dommage
Je n'arrive pas à m'empêcher de m'accrocher au bord
Sydney, Rasta ! Attends, il y a la Police
Venez là !
Bonjour - Bonjour
Ils sont gentils
Je fais aussi de la pêche à l'aimant
Ouais, mais c'est propre ici
Il y a beaucoup de pêcheur je pense
On a essayé partout là, rien
Que dalle, c'est propre.
Vous connaissez la chaîne YouTube ?
Pêcheur de Trésors
C'est vrai ? Ah ok
On pêche de partout en France, voire même en Europe, Berlin, Amsterdam.
Alors les trouvailles ? Des flingues ?
De tout, à Berlin on a trouvé un MP40
En plein centre une arme de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Dans quel état ?
Assez abimée
Mais bon, il a gardé sa forme
C'était en bakélite, pas en bois heureusement
Ah ouais !
J'ai vu cette vidéo
Vous vous faites arrêté par la police
Oui ils sont venus, il y avait des bombes,
Il fallait s'y attendre
Mais c'est bien.
Je vais me prend en photo avec vous.
Oui pas de problème
Mon gamin il doit vous connaitre
Surement
On va tester un peu en direct.
Allez-y les gars, j'espère qu'on va vous porter chance
On va voir
Tu sais que ici il y avait des U-boot ?
Il y a un gars avec sa femme, ils
sont sur YouTube aussi
Ils viennent de nuit avec un bateau
et ils viennent plonger dans les fosses des U-Boot
Bon, ils n'ont pas le droit
Oui logique
Ils essaient de choper des trucs au fond de la flotte
La base sous marine
Sympa.
Bon, on voulais pêcher à l'aimant ici
mais il y a trop d'algues.
Du coup, on a vu qu'il y avait un concert.
On va y aller comme ça.
Ça fait un peu punk à chiens mais bon
Ouais c'est bizarre, les gens nous regardent bizarrement
Ils sont tous bien habillés,
mais je pense que ça passe.
On va profiter de la ville de Bordeaux
À la semaine prochaine,
pour une nouvelle vidéo de pêche à l'aimant
Un couple mixte mais c'est beaucoup trop mignon !
Alors oui... Je me suis douché à priori quand même
Ma chienne est en chaleur en ce moment alors ils sont un peu chaud
Tout le monde est en chaleur ici
Arrêtes !